[Musique]
j'aime les gens qui doutent les gens
qu'ils trempaient coût de leur coeur se
balancer j'aime les gens qui disent et
qui se contredisent et sans se dénoncer
j'aime les gens qui tremble que parfois
il nous semble capable de juger
j'aime les gens qui passent moitié dans
leurs godasses et moitié à côté
j'aime
j'en sens même s'il passe pour des cons
[Musique]
ceux qui paniquent ceux qui sont pas nos
chine enfin un peu mon pot ce qui avec
leurs chaînes pour pas que ça nous gêne
montrent un bruit de grelots
ce qui ne rend pas compte de naître au
bout du compte que des ratés le cas pour
n'avoir pas su dire délivrez nous du
pirée garder le meilleur
j'aime leur petite chanson
même s'il passe pour des cons
[Musique]
j'aime les gens qui n'osent s'approprier
les choses encore moins les gens ce
qu'ils veulent bien n'être qu'une simple
fenêtre pour les yeux des enfants
ce qui sans oriflammes est daltonien de
la m'ignore les couleurs
ce qui s'entassent et pouvoir pour que
jamais l'histoire le rendent les
honneurs
j'aime leur petite chanson
même s'il passe pour des cons
j'aime les gens qui doutent mais
voudrait qu'on leur foute la paix de
temps en temps et qu'on ne les malmène
jamais quand ils promènent leur automne
au printemps qu'on leur dise que l'amf
et de plus belle flamme que tout c'est
triste qu est qu on les remercie qu'on
leur dise on leur crient merci d'avoir
vécu
merci pour la tendre
tant pis pour vous faire
you faire ce qu elle
t
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]